[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 23 juin le
département des yvelines poursuit son
engagement pour les zones rurales et
dévoile un nouveau plan pour
l'amélioration du service au public un
plan qui prévoit notamment
l'installation de la fibre optique avant
2020 marc lerouge est notre invité fil
rouge pour cette émission porte parole
du mouvement des jeunes avec macron dans
les yvelines nous reviendrons avec lui
sur cette semaine politique mouvementée
et les premiers pas à l'assemblée des
députés de la république en marche
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
locale retour sur le séminaire de
travail organisée par l'agglomération de
saint quentin sur le pl oui ou encore le
maire de bois d'arcy
à l'heure du bilan à mi-mandat 100
millions d'euros pour la ruralité le
département des yvelines a présenté
jeudi à rambouillet un nouveau plan pour
améliorer le service au public en milieu
rural près de 150 160 communes même sont
concernés par ce plan qui fait suite aux
assises engagé fin 2004 fin 2015 les
précisions avec ce reportage de charline
hurel les fibres optiques santé
éducation ou encore patrimoine
l'engagement du département pour les
zones rurales se veut ambitieux avec le
déploiement de la fibre optique avant
trois ans un deuxième bus pmi ou encore
le soutien financier pour lutter contre
les déserts médicaux des engagements
pour répondre aux angoisses des
habitants des zones rurales inquiet
notamment de la fusion envisagée avec le
département des hauts-de-seine et qui
consacre aussi le rôle majeur de la
ville de rambouillet rambouillet va
devenir la capitale de la ruralité
regroupe les deux territoires d'action
départemental dédié à la ruralité et on
les installe à rambouillet
et nous aurons naturellement des
antennes à houdan et dans le boni roi
qui sont très éloignées de rambouillet
et à côté de ça nous aurons aussi
l'agent ce que nous avons créé pour la
zone rurale ng neri qui sera installée
rambouillet et qui verra sa dotation
venant seul conseil départemental
doublettes
le nouveau plan présenté en présence
notamment du président du sénat
s'inscrit en complément des assises de
la ruralité engagé fin 2015 parmi les
autres propositions exposées le
développement des services au public
dans les gares rural la question de la
mobilité est très important il ya peu de
transport collectif dans l'espace rural
comment on résout la question de la
mobilité on n'a pas évoqué ce soir c'est
un sujet difficile à traiter
extrêmement onéreux et c'est un sujet
indispensable le plan pour
l'amélioration du service au public sera
votée avant la fin de l'année au total
d'ici 2021 le département des yvelines
promet d'engager 100 millions d'euros
pour la ruralité
elle trône tout en haut du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'agglomération vient d'installer ses
couleurs et son logo sur l'établissement
culturel une identité visible grâce à
cette nouvelle enseigne de 4 40 m²
installé sur la façade et qui je cite
correspond à une marque de soutien fort
et de l'engagement de l'agglomération
pour la culture vous envoyer quelques
images on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité de la semaine
et une semaine marquée évidemment empare
de la politique avec les visages des
nouveaux député des yvelines vous voyez
certains d'entre eux s'afficher à
l'écran 6 précisément et qui effectue
tous leur premier mandat en qualité de
député la république en marche rafle 11
des 12 sièges du département et dès
lundi les plus pressés d'entre eux se
sont rendus à l'assemblée nationale pour
recevoir notamment leur écharpe de
député et découvrir leur nouvel espace
de travail
reportage sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude un panneau une flèche
pour indiquer la direction celle de
l'assemblée nationale quelques heures
seulement après sa victoire dans les
yvelines
aurore bergé parmi les premières à
découvrir sous le soleil le palais
bourbon une prise de repères qui à 30
ans à peine en rappelle d'autres narnia
pas les parents qui m'accompagne donc ça
va j'ai quand même grandi depuis l'école
mais c'est beaucoup d'émotion c'était
très solennelle moi je suis déjà rentrée
à l'assemblée nationale
mais ça n'a rien à voir d'entrée pour la
première fois donc défiler la nation
pose devant les photographes et une
interview à la chaîne
après les jardins des quatre colonnes la
nouvelle députée dispose désormais d'une
mallette avec écharpe et règlement
intérieur et le respectent et dernière
étape de la visite l'hémicycle je pense
que c'est important aussi imprégné de la
solennité des lieux pour comprendre ce
qu'on attend de nous comprendre
la gravité du moment la responsabilité
qui doit être la nôtre voilà c'était
c'est symbolique mais c'est aussi très
important pour bien intégrer le travail
que l'on va faire à partir d'aujourd'hui
en tout ils sont 400 à découvrir
l'assemblée nationale cette semaine
parmi eux nadia et et béatrice piron de
la république en marche député de la 11e
et 3e circonscription des yvelines pour
les élus de la majorité présidentielle
l'apprentissage se poursuivra ce
week-end avec un séminaire de travail
prévues à paris et on va évoquer cette
actualité de la semaine avec notre
invité du jour marc lerouge bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le porte parole des
jeunes avec macron dans les yvelines
vous étiez aussi engagé dans cette
campagne des élections législatives et
notamment auprès de béatrice piron par
exemple dans la troisième
circonscription
comment s'est passée cette première
semaine ses premiers pas à l'assemblée
nationale vous avez eu des retours ça
s'est bien passé pour les nouveaux
députés écouter mais ça s'est plutôt
bien passé
ils ont pris leurs marques ils sont
allés voir visiter leur futur lieu de
travail leur futur bureau
c'est toujours impressionnant quand on
n'est pas habitué aux ors de la
république de se rendre compte
dans quel milieu vont ils vont devoir
évoluer pendant cinq ans donc a priori
tout s'est bien passé
il va y avoir un séminaire de travail
comme vous le disiez mai donc voilà au
travail alors séminaire de travail pour
précisions qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement que que vont faire ces 308
nouveau député de la république en
marche enfin ils sont pas tous nouveaux
mai sous l'étiquette de la république en
marche en tout cas ils le sont qu'est ce
qui est prévu c'est un petit peu une
rentrée des classes serre que certains
d'entre eux sont sont des députés qui
sont aguerris qui était déjà élu mais la
plupart n'a jamais connu ce mandat donc
il va falloir leur à pondre certain
nombre de choses un certain nombre de
réflexes
c'est comme tous les métiers quand on
rentre dans une entreprise quand on
rentre quelque part et bien on apprend
un métier il va falloir le faire il va
falloir connaître les codes parce que le
travail va commencer très vite la
session parlementaire commence la
semaine prochaine et il va falloir être
efficace et immédiatement oui avec des
textes notamment sur la moralisation de
la vie politique ou autre l'objectif
c'est aussi de créer une cohésion que
les gens apprennent à se connaître
la cohésion de la cré pendant la
campagne la cohésion la clé pendant la
campagne
des manuels macron ce qui a commencé il
ya à peu près un an dans les comités
locaux au niveau des circonscriptions
des départements ils ont appris à
travailler ensemble et puis on se
revoyait souvent malgré le fait qu on
venait tous d'un coin de département
parfois même on se retrouvait à des
meetings et là on se retrouvait à
beaucoup plus et puis il ya eu ensuite
la campagne législative et on a essayé
de faire une campagne où tous les
candidats se formait les uns les autres
se donnaient des bons plans des choses
intéressantes à faire à mettre en place
donc après oui on connait on connaît pas
les 300 litres je ne suis pas certain
que le groupe des socialistes nous
sommes des républicains se connaissait
tous parfaitement parker mais le
principe c'est surtout d'apprendre à ce
métier qui est un nouveau métier qui ne
doit pas en être un qui doit être un
passage de relais qui va durer cinq ans
et le principe c'est d'apprendre à
travailler très vite et efficacement de
fixer aussi d'aider des lignes rouges
des lignes à ne pas franchir à 308 on
imagine qu'il va y avoir forcément
parfois des désaccords et c'est logique
dans le débat politique est ce que c'est
aussi le cas de dire l'occasion de dire
voilà on ne peut pas dire ça ou franchir
tel telle position pour certains
éventuellement après si c'est sur le
fond le fond il a été abordé il ya un
contrat qui a été passé entre les élus
de la majorité emmanuel macron sur la
base du programme
donc ça c'est fait c'est réglé sur la
communication
mais y aura peut-être parfois des
des éléments de langage qui seront pas
les bons les peut-être des petites
erreurs des petits débordements les
choses à savoir aussi pour répondre aux
journalistes des choses à savoir et puis
peut-être des erreurs surtout et ça
faudra les pardonner parce que c'est pas
des professionnels de la politique en un
des chefs d'entreprise des avocats des
agriculteurs des fonctionnaires c'est ce
ne sont pas des professionnels et il va
falloir les juger sur ce qu'ils font est
parfois où il risque peut-être de ne pas
tout à fait quand même bien les codes
vous pensez ça veut simplement de
comprendre ça que justement ça fait
partie un peu du contrat le
renouvellement oui mais c'est aussi des
points un peu parfois négatifs ou plus
des cui difficile à négocier
je pense qu'ils ont compris parce le
résultat qu'on a eus pardon dans les
yvelines
on a eu onze députés sur douze
circonscriptions
et qu'est ce qu'on a pu entendre pendant
cette campagne ils n'y connaissent rien
ils ne sont pas compétents ils n'ont
jamais été élu et pourtant les gens leur
ont fait confiance donc je pense que ça
a commencé
ça a commencé ils se disent mais on va
leur faire on va leur donner leur chance
alors durant ce week-end dont on
évoquait tout à l'heure le séminaire de
travail
les élus vont devoir aussi nommer leur
leur président de groupe à l'assemblée
nationale selon toute vraisemblance et
devraient être l'ancien ministre richard
ferrand visé par une enquête
préliminaire dans pour les mutuelles de
bretagne en terme de renouvellement des
pratiques trouver plus ou moins sept
portes de sortir pour richard ferrand
c'est pas un peu dommage quand meme pour
l'image de ce parti qui se veut
justement basée sur le renouvellement
des pratiques des visages alors on a on
a glissé en fait avec le temps et c'est
peut-être les affaires qui ont fait ça
avant on avait des ministres a été mis
en examen il ya une quinzaine d'années
et puis c'était quand même un petit peu
compliqué on essayait de trouver une
porte de sortie à l'occasion d'un
remaniement
et puis maintenant on a quelqu'un qui
est soupçonné qui n'est pas mis en
examen qui est soupçonné et consorts du
gouvernement donc il ya un
renouvellement des pratiques on avait un
candidat qui avait dit si je suis mis en
examen je
n'irait pas au bout il est allé au bout
là on a quelqu'un qui est soupçonné et
d'ailleurs c'est un soupçon qui n'est
pas d'ailleurs judiciaire et une étude
près une enquête préliminaire mais lui
même n'est pas visé nommément
il est sorti du gouvernement on a trois
ministres modem qui était visé par
l'entremise de leur parti qui ne sont
pas mis en examen qui ne sont même pas
sous le coup d'une enquête préliminaire
et qui sortent du gouvernement ça
commence par là le renouvellement des
pratiques ou des richard ferrand si les
mises en examen selon vous devra quitter
son probable futur poste de président du
groupe en marche à l'assemblée nationale
je pense que le renouvellement des
pratiques ont peu difficile évidemment
en supposant oui on suppose mais si
effectivement il était mis en examen je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'ils
réfléchissent à son poste alors les élus
modem pour l'instant de enfin c'est sûr
ne vont pas participer à ce séminaire de
travail
on connaît l'actualité les démissions
qui ait lieu vous en parliez cette
semaine est-ce que ça va pas été utile
pour conforter cette image d'alliance de
travail en commun que les élus modem
soit convié éventuellement à ce
séminaire de travail
alors si ces deux groupes à l'assemblée
c'est un séminaire de groupe et c'est
très important qu'ils aient deux groupes
c'est très important que les élus modem
des gens n'ont pas compris ils tiraient
ce modem ça montre qu'il ya une majorité
qui marche sur ses deux pieds
il ya certes trois ministres modem qui
sont sortis du gouvernement
ils ont été remplacés par d'autres
modèles il ya un nouveau des ministres
monem d'un gouvernement il ya toujours
une majorité et la c1 seniors au travail
la république en marche et quand on
travaillera on travaillera avec la
république en marche et le groupe modem
il ya deux groupes qui forment la
majorité et on en a même un troisième
qui annonce vouloir travailler avec le
gouvernement
les élèves constructif et l'érudit
consultatif
on a envie de reparler juste sur le
modem pour continuer là-dessus ça reste
le même partenaire qu'il y a une semaine
et toute cette actualité cette
déferlante encore une fois qu'on a qu'on
a connu cette semaine ça reste ça reste
le même partenaire ils sont toujours
même poids dans la majorité ils ont
toujours leur quarantaine alors j'ai pas
le nombre exact mais leur quarantaine de
députés et puis
on a toujours toujours cet accord de
gouvernement avec eux et puis encore une
fois on a trois ministres qui ont décidé
de partir ils n'ont pas été mis à la
porte
ils ont fait l'annoncé par eux-mêmes
publiquement de sortir sylvie goulard en
premier puis ensuite françois bayrou
marielle de sarnez
ils font partie toujours de la majorité
alors écoutez à ce sujet bruno milliers
le président du modem 78 et élus sur la
9e circonscription des yvelines écouter
l'eau pourrait que les gens arrêtent de
faire des amalgames
il ya un accord de majorité
présidentielle qui a été conclu bien
avant le premier tour des élections
présidentielles entre le modèle et la
république en marche
d'accord cet accord court toujours et
continuera à courir cette majorité
présidentielle elle est sur ses deux
pieds le modem d'un côté il a un public
en marche était la volonté du présent
dans le public et ça reste la communauté
ça restera pas de provoquer on est au
travail pour le projet du président de
la république parce que ça nous paraît
être le seul projet qui vaille pour
sortir la france du marasme en cas
d'année voilà alors pour revenir sur la
démission notamment de françois bayrou
est ce que c'est pas non plus un
soulagement finalement pour pour
emmanuel macron de le voir démissionner
je ne pense pas que ce soit un
soulagement s'est jamais ça ne m'est
rien n'aurait pas été forcément très bon
de voir le ministre de la justice
inquiété par des affaires judiciaires
encore une fois c'était qu'un soupçon
c'est à dire que la justice fait son
travail les médias font le leur
l'aca a été révélée dans la presse il ya
des journalistes croit du monde qui
travaillaient dessus je ne crois pas que
chaque affaire révélée depuis 20 ans en
l'occurrence qui visent tous les partis
politiques à tour à tour a toujours
déboucher sur une mise en examen
donc il y avait une affaire qui était en
cours le ministre justice a décidé de
partir c'est très bien c'est tout à son
honneur
et ça change de feu qui s'accroche
jusqu'au bout et il a décidé pour être
tranquille lui pour préserver la
majorité pour préserver le président de
partir il l'a fait tout seul je pense
qu'il a fait avec émotion notamment
quand il a remis
quand il est la passation de pouvoir
après soulagement serait un vrai
soulagement de voir qu'il n'y avait rien
à voir et que peut-être demain il
pourrait être appelé à d'autres
fonctions
c'est pas un soulagement non plus parce
que quand le premier gouvernement a été
nommé étaient plutôt équilibrées hommes
femmes avec le modem avec tout le monde
le nouveau gouvernement ne l'ait pas
selon vous si il l'est mais il était
appelé à durer et la douce et pour
répondre c'est pas forcément le
soulagement parce qu'il était appelée à
durer et a duré longtemps et au bout de
cinq semaines devoir le changer c'est
pas forcément très bien
alors cette semaine a été forcément un
peu compliqué ce que vous avez eu peur
vous est ce qu'ils avaient craint de
tomber dans une spirale un peu comme
celle de l air durant la campagne
présidentielle
des soucis judiciaires du buzz
médiatique perpétuelle qu'on retourne
dans la même dans la même machine un peu
infernal
c'est un peu c'est un peu le combat
c'est un peu le combat qu'on a sur sur
la politique c'est à dire que vous avez
une affaire où même un soupçon
d'affaires ou ou des révélations qui
sortent et vous avez des partis
politiques qui s'en servent
c'est pas les médias qui le font monter
en épingle c'est les partis politiques
et pas souvent les mieux placés qui vont
vous expliquer que c'est totalement
scandaleux que c'est monstrueux que
c'est horrible
et ces mêmes partis politiques là si on
prend l'addition par exemple de leurs
affaires depuis des années ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de leçons à donner
je crois que c'est christian estrosi qui
l'a dit on est mal placé pour faire
cette leçon là donc on craint pas d'être
tombé dans une spirale
il ya des affaires il ya des questions
si la justice s'en saisit elle s'en
saisit et puis après la justice fait son
travail les médias font leur travail
nous on n'a pas de spirale spécialement
la seule spirale là qui commence
aujourd'hui c'est de mettre en oeuvre le
programme est de vraiment commencer à
obtenir des résultats
alors pour terminer cette interview je
voudrais vous faire réagir sur la
création d'un nouveau groupe au sein des
républicains les républicains
constructif avec lui dit ce qu'ils
pourraient voter plus facilement en
faveur de la politique du gouvernement
parmi eux on retrouve l'ensemble des
députés udi sont 18
la liste définitive n'est pas encore
arrêtée vous êtes membre de lady vous
étiez manger doit excuser moi vous étiez
membre de l'ue 10 mois responsable des
jeunes u 10 78 jusqu'à récemment quel
regard vous portez là dessus vous saluer
cette décision de créer un groupe a pas
un groupe à part ça après ça les regarde
moi je salue
la décision de députés de cire
constructif ce qui sous-entend qu'avant
il ne l'était pas c'est un petit peu
gênant maintenant je pense moi quand on
a signé cette tribune fin novembre en
appelant à soutenir emmanuel macron en
apprend un regard en appelant à regarder
ce qu'il allait faire
on a été suspendue pour ça et
aujourd'hui les élections sont passées
on a vu la campagne terrible qui a été
fait je parle pas du tout deux ont va
dire de tout ce qu'il a pollué mais ne
serait ce que sur le programme de
françois fillon qui n'étaient en rien
incompatible avec les valeurs du centre
ils ont mis six mois à s'en apercevoir
six mois et deux défaites électorales
plus tard le groupe uni par exemple a
fondu de moitié
et aujourd'hui il se disait on va
peut-être travailler avec emmanuel
macron c'est bien c'est très très bien
il fallait peut-être le faire avant et
aujourd'hui voilà ils vont penser qu'un
je lui dis va complètement basculé et
peut-être rentrer dans la majorité
présidentielle vous pensez que ce parti
là à vocation plutôt à travailler demain
avec la république en marche qu'avec les
républicains je pense qu'il ya un
évident parce qu at il continué je pense
que s'ils suivent l'acte fondateur de
l'uni
ça fait bien longtemps qu'ils auraient
dû être dans la majorité des manuels
macron maintenant s'ils veulent le faire
au cours de du monde a écouté c'est très
bien on est nous on est ouvert à tout le
monde toutes les personnes qui veulent
mettre en oeuvre le plan de
transformation et essayer de changer les
choses dans le pays
on accueille tout le monde merci marc
lerouge d'être venu en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le porte parole
dans les yvelines est des jeunes avec
macron on referme cette page politique
avec l'élection de didier baichère sur
la première circonscription des yvelines
un territoire pourtant a qualifié d'
imperdable pour la droite
les précisions avec ce sujet de michael
et demi d'euros douche froide pour les
républicains dans la première
circonscription des yvelines à droite
depuis 1963 le bastion a cédé sous la
vague de la république en marche
françois-xavier bellamy n'a pas réussi à
inverser la tendance du premier tour où
il avait réalisé seulement 27 49 % des
suffrages contre 42 15 % pour le
candidat de la république en marche
didier baichère malgré une belle
remontée l'homme politique de 31 ans
s'inclinent finalement 2 827 voix
j'espérais au soir du premier tour et
j'en étais convaincu que nous pouvions
rattraper le retard pourtant important
qui nous séparait de notre concurrent en
marche
c'était possible et on l'a prouvé
on a reçu 7000 voix de plus dans l'entré
deux tours mais on s'arrête sur le seuil
de cette victoire parce que je crois
profondément c'est que nous vivons
un phénomène national sur lequel
finalement on avait bien peu de prise il
suffit de constater les autres scores
des yvelines et de voir que là on fait
le l'un des meilleurs scores de toutes
les yvelines aujourd'hui et c'est
vraiment une fierté
la défaite de françois xavier bellamy
est également un coup dur pour le député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
le maire de versailles qui avait
remporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
56% des voix est prêt à travailler a
conseillé le nouveau député
je lui ai proposé tout alors se voir
rapidement
c'est non seulement important de suivre
en temps parlementaire
c'est évident il ya aucune raison partir
du moment où les électeurs ont décidé
qu'il était peu d'écouté on ne travaille
pas et puis qu'on travaille de façon
plus positive après l'annoncé officielle
dans sa permanence de campagne plage
charreaux à versailles didier peschard
analyse avec ses soutiens les scores
dans les différentes communes
dans le détail le candidat l'emportent
de 27 points à montigny le bretonneux et
de 41 points lui en cour à versailles
c'est françois-xavier bellamy qui
l'emportent ils totalisent plus de 60
29% des suffrages
je pensais pas honnêtement versailles
remonterait au temps par rapport à la
semaine dernière mais d'un autre côté la
semaine dernière c'était vraiment une
surprise d'être au coude à coude sur
versailles donc je pense que avait
beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient pas voté
la semaine dernière donc très bien pour
mon concurrent d'avoir remonté pour lui
à versailles comme ça ça partage un peu
la peine avec lui après avoir savouré sa
victoire dans sa permanence didier
baichère se remettra en marche dès ce
mercredi pour ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale dans le reste de
l'actualité locale cette semaine à saint
quentin en yvelines la mise en place du
plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal se
poursuit avec une nouvelle problématique
à régler l'arrivée de cinq nouvelles
communes l'an passé mercredi à un
séminaire était organisé pour répondre
aux questions des nouvelles villes
concernées par le p lui
précisions avec ce reportage de camille
lambert aménager un territoire à 12
communes en fonction des problématiques
de chacun c'est le défi de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lancé en 2013
le plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal
plui a été dévoilé aux cinq nouvelles
villes entrées en 2016 dans la
communauté d'agglomération on voit bien
que chaque commune à des projets
d'aménagement donc c'est comment on fait
pour les articuler puisqu'un projet
d'aménagement nécessairement des
conséquences sur la vie la côte et en
général en terme de circulation ne
serait-ce que ça donc ça oblige je
dirais les communes à travailler
ensemble pour poser leurs preuves de
leurs projets d'aménagement
on vit pas seul dans son coin il faut
qu'on partage avec avec ce qu'il ya
autour coignières les clayes-sous-bois
mort pas plaisir et villepreux ont
participé à un séminaire pour comprendre
les enjeux de ce pays lui quelles zones
seront urbanisés
quels logements seront construits et
quels espaces verts seront préservés
voilà quelques problématiques abordées
j'ai choisi venir à ce séminaire parce
qu'en fait la commune de coignières et
est en cours d'élaboration de son plan
local d'urbanisme est donc être ici ça
permet d'en savoir plus sur les plans
locaux d'urbanisme et à terme les plans
locaux d'urbanisme intercommunaux ce
genre de deux journées permet d'échanger
avec les autres communes pour partager
les expériences pour voir ce qu'on a en
commun ce qu'on a de différent
une cinquantaine d'élus et d'agents des
douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines étaient présents un premier
séminaire qui pourrait être suivi
d'autres rencontres du même type
2014-2017 l'heure est au bilan de
mi-mandat pour les maires des
différentes communes de saint quentin en
yvelines et à bois d'arcy philippe
benassaya et son équipe municipale ont
décidé d'aller rencontrer
les habitants dans les quartiers de la
ville une démarche de concertation lancé
il y a quelques jours
reportage de nicolas d'andré déjà trois
en trois ans à la tête de la ville de
bois d'arcy pour philippe benassaya
le maire fait un premier bilan de son
expérience il parcourt la ville avec un
bus électrique pour expliquer les
politiques qu'il a menées entre 2014 et
un moment aussi de concertation et de
critiques avec les arcisien il n'y a pas
eu d'augmentation d'impôts alors qu'il
n'avait eu dans les années précédentes
c'était assez élevé donc là ça s'est
stabilisé donc c'est déjà une bonne
chose
il ya un gros problème et circulation
dans le quartier sur la départementale
127 qui passe donc à côté de la mairie
donc tous les soirs c'est vraiment
saturé et on a du mal à rentrer chez
nous ou écouter j'en suis pas mécontent
monsieur benassaya de façon mieux on
manque de crèches
il ya une microcrèche que je pense qu'il
ya un projet d'ouverture d'une
microcrèche prochainement
mais ça ne suffira pas parce que
sachant que le temps d'attentes en fait
elle est en moyenne de 2 ans à
l'inscription
je pense que la priorité doit être
doit être fixée sur ce volet la création
de la police municipale construction du
gymnase colette besson ou encore la
rénovation du cosec plusieurs promesses
réalisé en 3 ans non sans difficulté
maintenant ce qui est très très
difficile
c'est la lenteur administrative on va
dire la lenteur pour monter un projet
c'est toujours très très très long il ya
énormément d accueil pour monter le
moindre projet ça c'est ça c'est
compliqué et ça c'est pénible pour te
dire dernière étape pour ce minibus
électrique ce samedi 27 juin au quartier
de la trembler le matin et quartier
saint-jean l'après midi on termine cette
émission avec la fête de la musique
mercredi soir de nombreux concerts à des
animations étaient organisées sur
l'ensemble du département et notamment
vous le voyez à l'écran à bois d'arcy et
à saint germain en lea voisins le
bretonneux les habitants ont pu voir
notamment se produire la compagnie
illicites dance une compagnie qui
forment et créer sur la ville nouvelle
depuis une vingtaine d'années nous avons
rencontré son fondateur olaf siby
regardez
[Musique]
aymeric 12 ans est la nouvelle recrue
d'illicite dance la compagnie saint
quentinois c'était danser tous les âges
depuis 1995 son fondateur c'est lui
aulas civile illicites vraiment au
départ donc il ya 22 ans quand j'ai
quitté black blanc beur et que j'ai pris
la décision de monter cette structure
mon objectif était d'avoir une structure
un peu intermédiaire je trouvais que
pour arriver dans le milieu
professionnel il ya un pas immense
on devait quitter la banlieue arrivée
sur paris connaître personne donc je me
suis dit je vais mettre une structure en
place qui va pouvoir former
professionnellement les jeunes les
jeunes qui ont envie de devenir
professionnel et leur apporter une vraie
rigueur et une vraie discipline
[Musique]
sa femme est illicite c'est avant tout
une compagnie professionnelle
aujourd'hui sept danseurs l'un composé
faut vivre son style au niveau national
et international
il ya une des chorégraphes qui
travaillent avec moi adeline qu'est la
chorégraphe de la compagnie
professionnelle qui a brillé sur
plusieurs plateaux télé et qui a été
aussi une danseuse sélectionnées pour
faire la publicité avec beyoncé pour
l'oréal il y avait trois danseuses de
suez à dîner et études donc une grande
fierté pour moi donc je me suis dit ma
petite formation dans l'ue elle n'est
pas si décalé que ça et puis après il y
en a eu d'autres ont gagné des concours
internationaux
après une pause d'un an la compagnie
repart sur les chemins de la création
son prochain projet le chorégraphie pour
la ryder cup la compétition
internationale des gauches qui aura lieu
à saint quentin en yvelines en septembre
2018 c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo
merci de nous avoir suivis retrouvez
tous nos reportages en replay sur tv fil
78 points comme ou l'application tv fil
bon week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]